on va faire trois groupes différents moi
faire la même chose
jackson danseurs pour la compagnie art
nouveau concept animé un petit atelier
de hip hop à l'école des sources de
saint germain en laye on a fait des pas
sur le côté en arrière aussi quand on se
croisait j'adorais les pattes ans et
beaucoup aimé j'aimerais refaire octobre
en recul reculer non ça je traiterai
accessible pour qu'ils puissent ça leur
donne envie en tout cas où un aperçu de
ce que c'est la danse j'ai déjà avoir le
rythme et de bouger dans l'espace déjà
ça leur apprend déjà beaucoup faisaient
leurs d'apprentissage pour les 18
enfants présents pour une chorégraphie
finale
puis à droite à gauche et l'autre
en arrière et le plus difficile
a été motivée donc c'est ça qui est ça
qui est cool c'est que lorsqu'ils sont
motivés ça même pour moi ça me donne
envie d'aller encore plus loin de leur
donner beaucoup plus de choses et quand
jackson montre aux enfants de quoi il
est capable
lorsque s'illumine ça m'a impressionné
choqué je trouve que ça ça doit des
années d'entraînement et que en fait
c'est et je suis content pour lui qu'il
a fait ça un léger aperçu du mardi 7
décembre au théâtre alexandre dumas de
saint germain en laye neuf danseurs de
la compagnie art nouveau concept seront
sur scène pour le spectacle à nos pas
j'aimerais bien voir je suis sûr que ce
sera bien parce que quand j'ai vu bien
axel je mets du ca frais extraordinaires
dont ses spectacles en mai on a essayé
en tout cas de véhiculer
mais la complexité d'être artiste de
données entre guillemets de montrer un
peu comment c'était quel est notre
univers parc on est passés par des joies
des peines des difficultés un deuxième
atelier similaire à celui ci sera animée
par jackson le 8 décembre prochain